i'm monger zhang i play shaolin which is
shanghi's sister and i'm simul liu and i
play shanghai today munger and i are
going to take the mcu trivia quiz to
find out how much we know about the
marvel cinematic universe you can take
the quiz with us by clicking the link in
the description box below i don't want
to jump the gun but i'm pretty i'm going
to be pretty good at this you're going
to kill it
okay question the first what year was
iron man aka the movie that started the
mcu released in theaters was it 2003
2005 2008 or 2010. i just watched it a
couple of days ago i think it's 2008. i
click on it
directed by john fabro iron man was
released in theaters in the u.s on may
2nd 2008. okay in thor what does thor
want another of when he's in the diner
is it a slice of pie
a cup of coffee a stack of pancakes or a
plate of bacon a cup of coffee i think
so because he takes the mug and he
smashes it on the ground right yep yep
cup of coffee final answer i'm pretty
good you're pretty good you're pretty
good at this i haven't even had to help
you at all next question in captain
america the winter soldier what does
steve famously say every time he runs
past sam is it on your left on your
right excuse me or watcher six we know
it's on your left click it of course
while running in washington dc steve
keeps laughing sam and saying on your
left in guardians of the galaxy which
infinity stone is inside the orb that
ronin and the guardians fight over so
the options are the mind stone the soul
stone the power stone and the time stone
oh that's easy uh it's the purple stone
which is the power stone correct the
power stone ronin is tasked by thanos to
receive the power stone on morag however
star-lord gets it first and wants to
sell it to the collector eventually
thanos gets the power stone after it's
handed to the nova corps try saying that
seven times fast in captain america
silverware who is on team iron man
the options are hawkeye spider-man
ant-man wanda well you know seeing as
spider-man was recruited by
tony
i feel like it's spider-man correct wow
we're doing so good someone's someone's
giving us uh uh easy balls uh softballs
i don't need you know what i mean in
black panther what are the female
warriors called this is a little harder
they're stepping it up a little bit all
right are they called the black panther
forces the wakandan warriors the kimoyo
soldiers or the dorami logic they are
called the dora milaji of course you
know how you and i know that yes we went
disneyland many times many times we've
been to disneyland many times you know
obviously one of our favorite places to
go is avengers campus of course one of
the amazing shows there is like the dora
milaji come out and they do this like
amazing show they look so good you must
go you must go i feel like we just did
an ad maybe we're doing an ad so we
could get more um
in avengers infinity war
all right which of these characters did
not get dusted after thanos snap was it
doctor strange
bucky barnes
groot or okoye doctor strange was like
it's the only way and then he disappears
right and then bucky is like steve i
don't feel so good and then and then you
know he disappears and then groot is
like i am groot and then he disappears
but okoye i think is still he's she's
still she's still kicking wow wow wow
are we a couple of mcu experts or what
right look at us in one division agatha
reveals that wanda uses what kind of
magic and the options are chaos magic
dark dimension magic asgardian magic
mirror dimension magic i don't know what
dark dimension magic necessarily is but
i would like to but i also know that's
probably not the answer i think the
answer is actually chaos magic yeah
and one of the biggest moments of the
series agatha tells wanda this is chaos
magic wanda that makes you the scarlet
witch in loki what item does mobius want
to have someday options are a dagger a
tiny mansion for his dog jet ski a flip
phone okay can we just talk about a tiny
mansion for his dog i wish that were the
answer that is the cutest thing and i
wish i had a tiny mansion for my dog
unfortunately it's not the answer to our
question the answer is a jet ski correct
not only does loki look through mobius's
jet ski magazine in episode two but in
episode four mobius tells ramona that
maybe in his other life he had one we
have reached the final question of our
mcu quiz and we are currently a flawless
nine for nine in shanghai what do the
villagers of tallow use to cover their
armor and weapons man if we don't get
this one that would look quite badly on
us the options are dargonite dragon
scales galactic glaze or vibranium do
you want to say it together yes one two
three
dragon scales this is my brother
and this is our perfect 10 for 10 score
it is revealed the villages of tallow
use dragon scales on their weapons and
armor including shang chi's iconic suit
in the film and with that a perfect
score for both manga and i
in buzzfeed's mcu quiz make sure you
watch shanxi and the legend of the ten
rings and and where can we can where can
we find it only in theaters right now go
now